so here's the way we're going to do it
i'm going to ask you all to um hold up a
hand right now everyone hold up a hand
okay
and in a second you're going to hold up
a number of fingers either one or two
here's the way we're going to do it if
you think that pace how fast i'm running
is the independent variable then in a
second i'm going to ask you hold up one
finger and if you think kilometers is
the independent variable then i'm going
to get you to hold up two okay one
finger let's let me write it down one
finger for pace as independent and two
four kilometers ready three two one make
your call
all right just look around the room for
me look around look around look around
so let me see if i remember this
most of you are suggesting the
kilometers
is the independent variable is that
right almost all of you i've got one
dissenting opinion down here anyone else
game sabrina's like oh i'm not sure okay
hands down hands down all right so hands
down the vast majority of you think that
kilometers are the independent variables
so
give me some justification anyway josh
the longer you're going to end up
running do you end up going slower
okay so here's a way that i said you
know the dependent variable sorry yes
the dependent variable changes in
response to the independent variable so
just what i'm hearing is that kilometers
i can change to be whatever i like but
then my pace slows down it's the one
that depends on kilometers is that a
fair like what most of you thinking
along those lines yeah which is a fair
call right in fact in reality that is
what i do because i don't have very good
control of my pace i run as fast as i
can and then i just slow down right
however
if i were a serious runner i'm just
amateur if i were a serious runner i'm
going to suggest that most of you would
be wrong
actually pace would be the independent
variable and kilometers would be
dependent now michael i'm not going to
necessarily put you on this one because
you're the only person but
you said
do you want to suggest a reason why it
would be the other way around because
it's something that you actually
directly control rather than something
that's remotely controlled ah-ha
okay okay so
did you catch that right let me say it
again because it's tricky you know it's
big room
pace is something i actually do have
very very direct control over from a
moment-to-moment basis like and so do
you am i gonna run fast as fast as i can
am i going to sprint or am i going to
take it easy so that i can go a longer
distance okay now in fact there have
been i excluded this data from the set
but there have been times where i've
literally said okay i'm just going to
run as fast as i can and at a certain
point i just can't run anymore right and
instead of slowing down i just stop and
i call it i'm like okay watch you're
done right
um
there are a couple of ones down here in
the lower areas where if i sprint as
fast i can i can probably go about two
kilometers and then i i'm done for the
day okay there's no more running that
happens after i'm walking home okay in
that case if you get this
the the independent variable we pace in
fact if i were a real trainer the real
reason why i would do that is because
you've got to do what they call like
high intensity low intensity and they
train you in very different ways right
one gets speed one gets duration okay
my key point here is you've got to think
about these things and the answer is not
always obvious okay
so that's the first thing
the second thing is uh these two
concepts are clearly connected as we
were just pointing out so there's a word
that we use a technical word that we use
when two variables like these connect in
a way that you can see in the data start
to see everyone tell me what it is
it's correlation can you please jot that
down underneath where you wrote
independent and dependent variables
so we see this relationship between in
my case kilometers and pace right
the correlation um is actually well
it's pretty decent right like the faster
i the longer i run the slower i go okay
now it's important to recognize that
sometimes you have what we call a really
strong correlation
the connection between these two things
is very obvious
now other times it's not so obvious and
i kind of feel like my running data sort
of fits into maybe this second category
here if i had more runs on the board
right we would say after strong you
might have a moderate correlation
uh down here it's like ah it's actually
quite vague but vague is not the
technical word they use the technical
word they use is a or no is it's not
strong it's
weak
and lastly we need to remember sometimes
there is just no connection whatsoever
sometimes there is no correlation so you
would say none you can look for a
pattern in the data but sometimes it is
not there and you search in vain for
some kind of connection okay
now uh you can do like a very rough
version of these obviously you don't
need to make need to make it super neat
you don't have to draw nicely circles
and that kind of thing but if you were
to draw a line of best fit we've looked
at these already right a line of best
fit across all of these they would look
something like let's go ahead and just
put some on right something like these
yeah they would still even though
there's a weakened connection here you
would still say this line is going sort
of in that direction okay
what is the gradient what can you tell
me about the gradient of each of these
lines of best fit
they're all roughly the same right and
importantly they're all increasing so
these would be what we call a positive
correlation
right there is no reason why a data set
should have to look like this in fact i
can take exactly the same data that we
just looked at with my running
here it is right here it's exactly the
same data but suddenly it looks really
different okay now i'm going to spoil it
a little bit for you but it's not that
hard to see my horizontal scale is the
same 5 10 15 20 et cetera it's still
kilometers okay but have a look over
here now on the left before i reveal it
what does this now look like in terms of
a vertical scale because it's not pace
anymore
still the same data set what do you
reckon sebastian
minutes
of what exactly like duration like how
long i've been running
so let's have a think about this right
does that fit the data
would i have fewer minutes as i run
further okay so we know it's not a bad
it's not a bad hypothesis because this
has to do with minutes
i'll give you another clue it is to do
with time but it's not that what do you
recommend
this is speed uh and it is actually in
fact average seekers over an entire
journey right so now you can see the
fact that i'm running slower perhaps you
might find this is actually a more
sensible graph right because slower
means it's going down right i'm down
here kind of around 12 kilometers per
hour ish right um think about that
exactly 12 kilometers per hour would be
precisely five minutes per kilometer
which you saw i was close to up on that
graph before but a little bit faster
right
so this is no longer like if we drew on
a line of best fit here it might look
something like that do you agree
the gradient is not positive anymore
it's
negative so this is no longer a positive
correlation
it's a negative correlation same data
set just visualize differently make
sense